bonjour sébastien chenu bonjour monsieur
vous êtes porte parole du rassemblement
national député du nord candidat à votre
réélection aux législatives on est
ensemble pour une interview de 20
minutes en partenariat avec la presse
régionale qui est représenté aujourd'hui
par le journal sud ouest avec vous au
jefferson des sports au reporter
politique défense au journal sud-ouest
bonjour des personnes bonjour alexandre
bonjour sébastien show du donjon
sébastien chenu on va commencer par
évoquer l affaire du stade de france
avec ce match aujourd'hui au stade de
france france danemark est ce que vous
craignez on est le même fiasco que
samedi dernier je ne souhaite pas
d'abord parce que pour l'image de la
france ça a été terrible et puis j'ose
espérer qu'à partir du moment où le
gouvernement était si mauvais dans
l'organisation la co organisation de cet
événement et on en a tiré un certain
nombre de leçons mais simplement sur cet
événement qui a car il faut bien dire
jeter le discrédit sur ce gouvernement
on a été face à quoi au déni du
gouvernement aux mensonges de gérald
darmanin à son incapacité d'ailleurs
hier encore en commission je crois que
c'est au sénat ou à l'assemblée par le
sénat au cenasa de donner la nationalité
des gens qui ont été interpellés c'est à
dire la volonté de dissimuler à la
représentation nationale un certain
nombre de données et puis l'incompétence
et l'impuissance face à ce que la france
connait jeudi face à ce que la france
connaît parce que ça ne se passe pas
comme ça dans les autres pays européens
en particulier c'est le sien show du
pardon mais emmanuel macron maintient sa
confiance à gérald darmanin comment vous
l'expliquez est ce que gérald darmanin à
la confiance de la police eh bien il a
tort le président de la république a
tort mais parce que ces gens ne veulent
pas voir la réalité en face il préfère
une crise diplomatique se brouillent et
accusé les britanniques plutôt que de
reconnaître la mauvaise organisation de
l'événement mais aussi les difficultés
que nous traversons de façon tout à fait
spécifique en france qui sont celles de
bandes de racailles totalement hors
contrôle avec des gens qui n'ont rien à
faire en france des gens qui ne sont pas
français les images gens qui sortent de
problèmes sébastien chenu c'est parce
qu'on voit on voit des familles ils ont
été gazés des supporters anglais enfin
on veut gaz lacrymogène avec désormais
on sait ce qu'on voit surtout des
racailles qui viennent des trousses et
des gens qui viennent voir un match et
ça c'est inadmissible
si aujourd'hui il doit être vécue dans
notre pays comme dangereux d'aller en
famille voir un match alors non
seulement l'image de notre pays va être
sérieusement abîmée je crois qu'elle l'a
été si je lis la presse étrangère mais
alors il ne sera plus possible de rien
faire dans certains coins de france il
ya des hordes de racailles en seine
saint denis qui sont identifiés qui sont
connus qui sont encore aujourd'hui en
liberté mais nous nous parlons quand
gérald darmanin se refuse de donner les
nationalités des gens interpellés samedi
long en réalité il avoue tout se dire
qu'on a un problème de bandes de
violence de racailles d'immigration dans
ce pays on regarde pas les choses en
face donc ça se reproduira un moment
nous d'ailleurs ça s'est déjà produit de
par le passé quand il y à des heures sur
les champs elysées les soirs de match et
que personne n'ose sortir parce que
c'est un bazar sans nom quand il y
adhérer sauve à des rodéos sauvages dans
les dans les cités d'agir on voit la
vérité en face les gens voient la
réalité il voit la violence de cette
société et on a un ministre un président
de république qui refuse de prendre à
bras le corps ça parce que les
thématiques du régalien l'ordre public
la sécurité sont pas des thèmes qui
plaisent à emmanuel macron considère que
les français lambert d'avec leur
insécurité quand vous parlez est bien
des nationalité des personnes
interpellées voulait faire la différence
entre britanniques et français mais ce
pays deux gardés à vue britannique
visiblement d'après ce que nous avons vu
même si les britanniques ont été
largement accusé par le gouvernement
observez le gouvernement a d'abord
accusé les britanniques puis il a accusé
les grévistes de la ratp puis l'accusé
et tourniquet puis l'accusé les faux
billets ap il a menti mais en réalité il
n'a jamais accusé ou exonérés en tous
les cas de responsabilité
toutes ces racailles qui sont connues et
dont il apparaît que certains n'ont rien
à faire sur un territoire français était
déjà dans l'obligation de quitter le
territoire ils sont encore là il se
comporte mal je veux dire on a un
problème ne pas le voir de pauvres ir
les yeux c'est ne pas traiter le
problème la responsabilité laquelle
niveau sébastien chenu du haut niveau de
la préfecture de police avec le préfet
didier lallement au niveau du ministère
de l'intérieur mais le préfet didier
lallement c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur le préfet c'est le
représentant de l'état ce préfet dont on
sait qu'il a souvent la main lourde sur
les gens faibles les familles les gilets
jaunes etc est incapable de faire
respecter l'autorité de l'état en
seine-saint-denis nous l'avons vu
tirons-en les conséquences et gérald
darmanin s'il avait un peu de panache on
aurait lui-même tiré les conséquences en
dix ans c'est beaucoup de pays ailleurs
qui lorsque administré dans un tel échec
face à un tel échec tire sa révérence je
n'ai pas été mieux ou alors aller il
même s'il n'avait pas quitté aurait
commencé par présenter des excuses aux
britanniques au lieu de les accusés
auraient commencé par dire nous n'avons
pas été au niveau nous n'avons pas
anticipé enfin cet événement on le
connaissait c'est pas nouveau ce qui se
passe au stade de france sébastien joly
publié c'est pas nouveau non plus
sébastien chevalier est qu'au fond à
cette histoire du stade de france n'est
pas une aubaine politique pour leur
assemblée nationale qui revient sur ces
thèmes du lien entre insécurité et
immigration monsieur c'est pas nous qui
dissimule on les choses c'est le
gouvernement qui dissimule c'est le
gouvernement qui ment c'est le
gouvernement qui est dans le déni alors
après on est là mais les gens nous
sanctionne aux élections bayat quoi les
fonctionnaires élections est ce qu'on a
envie d'être gouvernés par des gens qui
ne savent pas organisé aujourd'hui une
rencontre sportive au stade de france
sans que ça devienne un fiasco européen
est ce qu'on a envie de faire confiance
à des gens qui refusent de voir la
réalité en face qui monte aux français
non je crois qu'on n'a pas envie de leur
faire confiance et c'est vrai et
finalement vous avez raison la meilleure
réponse qu'on peut apporter dans ces cas
là bas c'est de voter les 12 et 19 juin
pour des députés l'opposition du
rassemblement national s'il est jeune
même marine le pen l'a reconnu elle l'a
dit il y aura un premier ministre m'a
contre guillemets c'est inéluctable donc
est ce qu'elle n'a pas fait une croix
sur législatives comment vous pouvez
dire à la fois ça et on tente votre
patronne dire maintenant toute façon il
y aura une majorité en marchant semble
en tout cas à l'assemblée nationale
marine le pen dit la vérité aux français
elle les emmène pas dans des impasses ou
dans des culs-de-sac a dit les
institutions quand il n y en a pas un en
particulier ne dis pas ça est dit les
institutions en particulier le
quinquennat ont été faits sur mesure
pour que les présidents dispose de
majorité et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
s'est passé à chaque élection
présidentielle majorité courte majorité
relative peut-être mais souvent en tout
cas toujours jusqu'à présent par don les
présidents de la république entretenu
ses majorité face à la majorité
position nous souhaitons être cette
opposition quand vous avez moins de
quinze députés vous ne comptez pas ou ne
vous fait pas entendre quand vous avez
entre 15 et 150 députés c'est ce que dit
marine le pen donnez-moi 150 députés et
nous allons contrer macron le reste les
histoires de jean luc mélenchon je serai
premier ministre israélien
éventuellement venir plateau mais
premier ministre j'avais pas français
qu'il croit on va parler en quelques
minutes de cette campagne des élections
législatives pour le rassemblement
national mais d'abord j'aimerais qu'on
évoque la visite hier du président de la
république emmanuel macron à marseille
sur le thème de l'école il a défendu son
projet d'école du futur plus de liberté
pour les instituteurs pour les
directeurs d'école sébastien chenu est
ce que vous êtes convaincu c'est lui
parce que cette école du futur
d'emmanuel macro pour d'abord moi je
vois surtout des enseignants qui sont
livrés à eux mêmes hier j'ai été frappé
par deux choses d'abord un ministre de
l'éducation nationale totalement
transparent alors c'est peut-être le
nouveau mode de fonctionnement du
gouvernement façon elisabeth bornes ça
qu'on a nommé des gens et finalement on
les entend jamais y'a pas que s'il n'y a
pas d'image on les a déjà oublié on ne
sait rien oui enfin il peut cette rue on
parle de lui alors faut pas sortir dans
ces cas là vous allez nous parler de
l'école du futur c'est pour rien dire il
est mise l'éducation nationale en fait
je crois qu'il ya aucune vision de ce
qu'il veut faire et puis autre chose
jeudi des enseignants sont livrés à eux
mêmes c'est ce qu'on entendait avec eux
cette espèce d'épidémie vous avez vu de
tenue islamique dans le pays dans les
écoles enfin est ce qu'on est en train
de se rendre compte que après le burkini
on est en train de faire face a encore
des coups de boutoir d'associations de
structures islamiques du futur saad mais
la voir et si c'est pas un danger
pédagogique vous habitez ou et si c'est
un enjeu c'est comme le sens mais c'est
un enjeu terrible parce qu'on voit que
l'école qui repose sur un des fondements
important qu'est la laïcité dans notre
pays est victime de coups de boutoir de
plus en plus fort pour rompre cette
laïcité et l'école du futur de demain
que doit pas l'être alors être une école
dans lesquelles chacun vient avec une
tenue religieuse une école
communautariser peut être que ça ferait
plaisir à pap ndiaye qui est un militant
mêlant nota le développement j'ai
pédagogique mais bien sûr mais on peut
parler de protégea pédagogique à partir
du moment où la laïcité respecte et je
vous donne un autre exemple que
j'entendais ce matin par des professeurs
justement qui disait dans nos cours il
ya des élèves qui se bouche les oreilles
quand on parle de musique c'est un
projet pédagogique avec d'ailleurs que
de faire entrer l'éducation artistique
le plus loin possible le plus fort
possible dans l'éducation nationale eh
bien on voit aujourd'hui que sur le
terrain il y a des gens qui pour des
raisons religieuses ne veulent pas de
ces projets pédagogiques donc l'école du
futur c'est pas une école à la carte
c'est pas une école où chacun vient
prend un peu ce qu'il veut pense qu'il
ne veut pas et que fais de la musique ou
n'en fait pas avec une tenue religieuse
n'en fait pas mais bien entendu c'est
une école qui délivre le même
enseignement à tout le monde et qui tire
vers le haut eh bien voyez vous moi je
crois que l'on peut me parler de projets
pédagogiques à partir du moment où les
fondements de l'école sont solides et où
on ne laisse pas le corps enseignant
sans aucune directive parce que le corps
enseignant aujourd'hui nous dit face à
ces problèmes d'intrusion du religieux
dans notre école nous sommes livrés à
nous mêmes vous regrettez vous regretté
jean michel blanquer a quand on vous
écoute ah bah quand je vois pape ndiaye
mais pour l'instant je veux pas juger là
ce que fait pape ndiaye je ne connais de
pas peu dire que ce qu'il a écrit c'est
à dire un homme qui dit que notre pays
est un pays au racisme structurel un
homme qui va dans des réunions
interdites aux blancs très particulier
quand même je note que il est un
ministre communautariste on va voir ce
qu'il fait mais je note aussi que face
aux coups de boutoir communautariste
pour l'instant y'a pas que son n'y a pas
d'image alors de déplacement cette
semaine pour emmanuel macron on a
l'impression que ça y est il est entré
dans la campagne des législatives oui
bah vous savez il serait temps enfin je
veux dire le président de la république
est élu depuis deux mois bientôt on ne
s'est rien passé les bracelets montres
les français depuis deux mois lorsqu'il
met de l'essence dans leur voiture je
passe quelque chose pour leur
portefeuille lorsqu'ils vont au
supermarché acheter des tomates et des
oeufs ils seront tous le compteur à tout
le monde explique delahousse faux plat
ou sousse et le cynisme des modèles
macron qui en réalité n'en a rien à
faire des difficultés que traversent les
français il est là pour durer et il est
là pour durer pour ensuite dépasser les
élections législatives le fait que ça va
le moins de bruit possible pour ensuite
tapé très fort avec la réforme des
retraites faut passer les législatives
le plus possible entre les gouttes
malheureusement il ya eu le stade de
france malheureusement il ya pouvoir
d'achat malheureusement il ya des coups
de boutoir communautariste il se rend
compte que c'est difficile donc un
moment il sort du bois parce qu'il voit
bien que la réalité le rattrape vous est
ce que disait lacan la réalité c'est un
coup de poing dans la figure et en fait
la réalité elle est en train de revenir
passe à emmanuel macron c'est madame
mâcon qui nous disait au moment des
présidentielles je fais pas campagne
parce que je suis au téléphone avec
vladimir poutine tous les jours bon
finalement quand il a senti qu'il
fallait aller faire un peu campagne il a
raccroché le téléphone ben là c'est un
peu pareil en fait emmanuel macron
voulait pas se mêler des problèmes du
quotidien des français il lui revienne
en pleine figure donc maintenant il y
retourne parce qu'ils se disent est en
train de me rattraper oui c'est en train
de le rattraper et beaucoup plus vite
qu'ils ne le pensent alors en tout cas
son premier déplacement cette semaine
c'était mardi soir à l'hôpital de
cherbourg pour évoquer à la crise de
l'hôpital il a annoncé une mission flash
d'un mois pour faire le diagnostic des
problèmes de l'hôpital dans les
différents territoires est ce que c'est
une solution à la hauteur de l'urgence
mais je me demande jusqu'à quand va se
moquer des français une mission flash
d'un mois je dis moi j'ai été député
pendant cinq ans à la commission des
affaires sociales dans le derby
bourguignon était présidente on sait
précisément là où il manque des lits à
quoi servait d'ailleurs les ars si ce
n'est à à flécher ou à dire ou à
organiser l'hôpital public avec toutes
les difficultés et toutes les
insuffisances qu'on connaît si ce n'est
qu'elle rend faire un état des lieux à
l'état des lieux on le connaît merci
beaucoup si au bout de cinq ans de
quinquennat macron ils en sont encore à
se demander où il manque des lits c'est
catastrophique le ségur de la santé n'a
pas répondu aux attentes en matière de
santé publique il ya trois leviers à mon
avis qu à actionner qu'ils n'ont pas
actionner lé recrutement c'est à dire le
nombre de personnel dans les hôpitaux
publics le compte n'y est pas on ferait
mieux de réintégrer d'ailleurs
immédiatement les 15000 soignants c'est
qu'ils ont une formation aussi le même
on en a quinze mille ha qui sont formés
et disponibles pour l'été parce qu'on
nous dise à être l'été rouge dans les
hôpitaux en à 15000 soignants qui ont
été mis à pied parce que pas vaccinés
qui sont formés et disponibles au déjà
les réintégrer l nombre il ya les
rémunérations et l'attractivité de la
profession sur ça on n'est pas allé
jusqu'au bout je me rappelle encore de
grève de sage femme qui avait été
totalement méprisé par le ségur de la
santé et puis à l'organisation de
l'hôpital public est en fait c'est
probablement là doute de tout ça c'est à
dire la pardonnez moi du terme et la rue
médicalisation des directions d'hôpitaux
c'est à dire avoir du personnel médical
des médecins qui dirigent ou qui
codirige et pas uniquement des
technocrates qui dirige l'hôpital public
est et bien ces trois leviers il faut
les actionner on les a demandé pendant
cinq ans visiblement le gouvernement
toujours au point mort l'armé au pied
rien n'est fait on nous parle d'une
mission flash pour faire le constat
enfin c'est pas du tout au niveau du
défi majeur qui est devant nous et vous
savez ce qu'on voit dans notre pays
c'est en fait un effondrement des
services publics au sens large la
justice la police des hôpitaux éducation
et de l'autre côté un pays qui est
ouvert à toutes les violences qui
viennent en particulier de l'extérieur
et pas de grande bretagne visiblement et
la rencontre de ces deux phénomènes des
constructions effondrement des services
publics violence de la société
ensauvagement de la société nous donne
un paysage sur lesquels il faut réagir
avec lui à une élection présidentielle
et marine le pen l'a perdu oui d'accord
mais pas parce que même nom met d'accord
et fort peu c'est à terre donc on fait
plus rien en fait donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a besoin député du rassemblement
national donc c'est exactement pour ça
qu'on a besoin d'envoyer 100 150 députés
du rassemblement national à l'assemblée
pour s'opposer pour proposer s'opposer à
la réforme des retraites à 65 ans qui
arrive pour proposer sur le pouvoir
d'achat proposé un panier à 0 % par
exemple de tva sur des produits première
nécessité il ya un besoin urgent très
justement sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est à
l'autre urgence du gouvernement avec un
paquet de mesures qui est prévue pour
l'été qui sera débattu au parlement avec
notamment la prolongation du bouclier
tarifaire sur le gaz électricité au
total entre 15 et 20 milliards d'euros
de mesures est ce que les futurs députés
rassemblement national voteront quand
même ces mesures on va regarder ce qui
est là dedans deux choses d'abord ce
vous dit ce sera pour cet été donc ce
sera pour la rentrée donc en fait depuis
l'élection des modèles macro il se
serait rien passé et il y aura des
chèques à la rentrée qui vont tomber sa
semaine en train de dire n était à la
rentrée quelques chèques vont tomber ils
ont pu aller plus vite et ne pas
attendre le oui il aurait pu aller plus
vite winslet exemple je vous donne un
exemple soit pu faire deux choses une
grande conférence sur les salaires nous
on propose d'augmenter les salaires de
10% avec de l'autre côté un gel des
cotisations patronales une conférence
sur les salaires c'était possible de
tout de suite sans faire entrer des
députés immédiatement lister les 100
produits de première nécessité sur
lesquels nous demandons une tva à zéro
pour cent eh bien c'était possible
immédiatement aller vite pour donner des
réponses immédiates aux français mais
aussi des réponses pérennes quand on
demande la baisse de la tva à 5,5 sur
les énergies l'essence électricité etc
c'est pour que ça dure dans le temps
c'est pas un chèque fonds rendez compte
que la politique des chèques non sens
économique on donne des chèques pour
combler des taxes et bien elle a abouti
à ce que des députés européens ou des
prisonniers touche d'échec je veux dire
au bout d'un moment si on se rend pas
compte que c'est mal calibré que c'est
mal pensé que ça ne répond pas aux
préoccupations
ces gens là n'ont pas de nom pas de bon
sens donc nous nous demandons des
mesures pérennes qui durent dans le
temps qu'ils soient immédiate pour
soulager les français alors vous dites
l'échec c'est un non sens économique est
ce que baisser la tva sur les carburants
ce n'est pas un non sens écologique non
pas du tout parce que de l'autre côté
évidemment il ya toute une politique
notamment en matière d'hydrogène
d'énergie et s'est développée on en a
beaucoup parlé on a fait nos
propositions et on continuera à les
porter il s'agit monter les éoliennes
par exemple oui mais bien sûr mais il
faut arrêter avec les éoliennes il avant
de les démonter il faut arrêter d'en
implanter de nouvelles c'est moi je suis
élu du nord région des hautes france
région qui est particulièrement touchée
qui la plus exposée par l'implantation
du nombre d'éoliennes avant de les
démonter arrêtons déjà d'en monter
arrêtons avec cette cette escroquerie
que sont les éoliennes alors vous êtes
sur la solution de la baisse de la tva
jean luc mélenchon lui il propose de
bloquer les prix est ce que c'est pas
plus efficace notamment pour épargner un
peu nos finances publiques c'est une
dinguerie vous avez des hausses de
matières premières la hausse du blé par
exemple la hausse d'un certain nombre de
deux matières premières dans notre pays
notamment conséquente à la guerre en
ukraine mais après tout vous avez des
hausses de matières premières vous aurez
donc si les prix étaient bloquées des
boulangers par exemple prenant sept
puisque je parle du blé qui vendrait à
pertes totalement un non sens on
retrouve là les vieux discours
communiste dirigiste qui sont des
catastrophes une fois qu'elle s'applique
sur le terrain mais jean-luc mélenchon
voilà est en fin de course ont été il
est même pas candidat aux élections il
sera jamais premier ministre il raconte
donc aujourd'hui absolument n'importe
quoi pour retrouver du carburant parce
qu'après avoir raconté n'importe quoi
aux français faut durer un mois et demi
aujourd'hui les français ont compris que
c'était évidemment un coup de com et
donc il en vient à raconter strictement
n'importe quoi tout ça n'est pas sérieux
tout ça n'est pas très sérieux demain on
va avoir besoin d'une opposition
sérieuse sans quoi les députés
rassemblement national sont des gens
formés et qui demain seront des
opposants syriens et ça nous amène à
parler de la campagne des élections
législatives notamment du point de vue
du rassemblement national est ce que
marine le pen elle n'a pas perdu ce
statut de première opposante à emmanuel
macron un statut piqué par jean luc
mélenchon mais on vous les journalistes
vous avez déjà fait le coup il ya cinq
ans moi je me souviens il ya cinq ans il
y avait quinze députés mélenchonistes
qui était entré on t'avait dit ça y est
c'est l'opposition emmanuel macron parce
qu'il s'agissait il arrivait en match de
foot dans l'hémicycle ou mettez trois
boîtes de conserve sur les deux ou
sortait trois boîtes de conserve dans
l'hémicycle il faisait de la com c'est
pas ça être une opposition sérieuse
d'ailleurs on l'a vu ils n'ont pas été
qualifié pour le second tour d'élection
présidentielle les français ont fait
confiance à marine le pen que nous
puissions sérieuse c'est aussi siégé
aller en commission faisait
sur le dernier quinquennat la présence
de marine le pen sur les commissions et
textes importants a été remis en cause
non mais je suis et mes camarades la
députée aussi classé parmi les 150
députés les plus actifs pourtant nous
avons zéro moyen très peu de temps de
parole quand on n'a pas de groupe pas de
moyens déposé des propositions de loi
dans des niches parlementaires donc je
pense qu'avec la faiblesse des moyens
que nous avons eu nous avons été
catégorisé parmi des députés les plus
actifs donc nous n'avons pas à rougir et
demain il nous faut un groupe je disais
tout à l'heure quand vous n'êtes pas le
groupe où il comptait pas si vous avez
150 députés vous contrer la majorité si
vous avez une majorité députés ont
refait le match les français n'auront
pas le match parce qu'ils vont pas
ajouter une crise institutionnelle et
politique à la crise sociale économique
mais ils ont envie d'avoir des gens qui
compterait manel macro sur les objectifs
du rassemblement national au début de
cette campagne à marine le pen elle
évoqué et bien déjà la nécessité d'avoir
un groupe au moins 15 députés ensuite eh
bien on a parlé d'une soixantaine de
députés maintenant eh bien elle
communique sur ses 150 députés quel est
votre objectif précisément elle a raison
d'ailleurs bas les arbres n'atteignent
jamais le ciel c'est le maximum de
députés qu'on puisse avoir et vous savez
on va avoir des députés partout en
france monsieur qui est de sud-ouest oui
nous avons des députés dans le sud-ouest
faisant début députés dans les hauts de
france auront des piquets en paca nous
aurons des députés dans le grand est en
bourgogne nous auront débuté en ile de
france également de sa tournée the road
et à se démarquer est ce que vous
attendez un député à saint tropez un
député rassemblement national oui nous
attendons un député rassemblement
national visionnement oui je pense que
philippe lottiaux qui étaient élus du
secteur sera député de saint tropez
rappelle précisément d'une
circonscription parce que pour l'équipe
on a cité un autre candidat j'ai cité le
d'autres en tout cas est-ce que vous
avez un chiffre précis qui serait
satisfaisant en nombre de sièges pour le
rng pas de chiffres précis parce que je
n'ai pas ouvert de
deux roulottes de madame irma donc je
n'ai pas de chiffres précis le minimum
c'est un groupe il n'y a pas de maximum
et mais je pense que si les français
veulent vraiment envoyer un signe contre
emmanuel macron de remparts au maquereau
nisme et à toute sa brutalité il leur
faut des étudiants 5 ans la différence
entre 2017 et maintenant parce qu'en
2017 marine le pen et toucy au deuxième
tour de la présidentielle vous n'arrivez
pas à faire un groupe à l'arrivée à
l'assemblée nationale malgré toutes ces
voix est là pourquoi ce serait le cas
cette fois ci parce que je pense que les
électeurs assemblée nationale on était
fier de la campagne qui a été menée vous
savez on a atteint un score qui n'avait
jamais été atteint pour le compatriote
près de 42% des voix au second tour
l'élection présidentielle les français
nous disent d hector marine le pen nous
disent sur le terrain quelle belle
campagne on n'était pas si loin on a
fait quelques jeux y sont très fiers et
ils ont envie d'avoir des députés
rassemblement national pour porter leur
parole faisait ce que me disent souvent
les électeurs tu vas parler pour nous
les électeurs du rassemblement national
ils vont non seulement parler mais agir
pour tous ces français il ya 42 % des
français qui ne veulent pas n'ont pas
voulu des modèles macron ils doivent
être représentés au moins ce niveau là
ce que vous admettez que cette campagne
des législatives pour le rassemblement
national elle un peu étrange un peu
poussive avec une marine le pen qui
n'est pas vraiment la chef de file et
qui est caché derrière jordan bardella
bas marine le pen et tous les jours sur
le terrain il sera aujourd'hui dans le
nord d'ailleurs chez moi pas seulement
dans ma circonscription d'ailleurs elle
sera dans le temps elle fait du terrain
mais c'est un peu salée j'entends ce
qu'on disait au moment des élections
présidentielles abu marine le pen elle
est partie en province sur les marchés
quand même on l'entend plus tellement
eric zemmour occupe le terrain
médiatique on a vu ce que ça donnait oui
marine le pen elle va au contact des
français parce que c'est là probablement
où elle est la meilleure et c'est là
probablement où les français ont envie
de la retrouver donc oui marine le pen
et jordan bardella sont au contact des
français tous les jours mais pourquoi
marine le pen refuse les débats
télévisés dans cette campagne à la fois
niveau local et au niveau national avec
jean luc mélenchon et isabelle borne
mais j'ai pas compris qu elisabeth
bornes dont on n'a plus entendu parler
depuis qu'elle a été nommée ai eu envie
de faire un débat les qui que ce soit
donc s'il y avait deux bornes veut faire
un débat avec marine le pen je suis
persuadé que marine le pen sera capable
de trouver sa voie et jean luc mélenchon
lui propose un débat michel sardou voyez
le niveau de sérieux de cette campagne
donc nous nous deux ton avec des gens
qui ont en main aujourd'hui la destinée
les destinées du pays s'est déjà belle
bourde veut débattre je suis sûr qu'elle
trouvera des interlocuteurs au
rassemblement national jordan bardella
où marine le pen soit à mon avis assez
intéressé le problème c'est que le
gouvernement devait débattre avec
personne car il ne veut pas tu entres
dans la lumière ses sombres desseins
merci beaucoup et ça va être un pionnier
de l'avoir été à notre invité politique
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup jefferson et
sport pour le journal sud ouest on va
d'ailleurs regardez la une aujourd'hui
du journal sud ouest qui est consacré à
la mort d'un bébé dans la commune de la
traîne en gironde après une circoncision
dans une maison louée pour pratiquer des
circoncisions rituelles et l' enquête
doit dire justement s'il ya un lien
entre cette opération et à la mort de ce
bébé
[Musique]